I'm very very predicated on running a  marathon in a world that I think is  running a sprint I think when we think  about 2014 and when I think about the  entrepreneurs in this room and marketers  are the brands that I work with we live  in a world where people lack patience we  just don't have patience and I promise  you that if you're able to whether it's  financially or emotionally put yourself  in a position to have patience you have  a far better chance of succeeding your  decision-making path becomes far clearer  and you build much more leverage to  actually build wealth or work-life  balance or legacy or whatever makes you  tick